on a a difficult start for you to this
tournament but now you played one of the
co-leaders going into this round and you
were dominant how do you feel right now
okay of course so I'm very happy to win
my first game in the tournament and I
hope not the last one and uh I hope to
show like this quality of Chess I was
performing today so I hope to continue
this and how did you approach today's
game what type of positions were you
looking to get out of the opening I
thought maybe it was a little bit
drawish but I then I saw that now uh
uh Carlson bit me up on this line so I
said probably I can play this line as
well and this one with Queen to C1 no no
no this one this one I meant I meant
taking on D5 taking on D5 first 65 it
looks like uh I'm allowing her to
get her a light squared Bishop out but
then there is still like many chances to
fight
what are the details of this position I
think like uh in um
H3 right Bishop H7 H3 something like
Castle G4
yes G4 Bishop from probably remember
yeah and then it was something like
Bishop it took with the sixth Queen B3
if I'm not mistaken yes
yeah and um
so this was my uh
idea approach so it's possible even if
it's not a computer doesn't give
Advantage right here not on this line
but I mean like in general you're
looking for some end game with a little
bit of pressure I didn't know like I had
like a different line and the big local
this morning I wanted to play different
but then I changed it like 15 minutes
before the game before I changed my mind
and I decided to play this one well it
definitely worked today wouldn't you
feel like you're taking over at the
initiative actually like she played like
for a while and it was the cold position
but I think like in certain points she's
just what I don't know what happened she
starts playing like really
taking a lot of time and playing not her
like best chess definitely like her
quality and first two rounds was much
much better and here was many
interesting options for example if you
go back couple moves so I think was
interesting okay before before it's
interesting but you need to secure your
night on ec4 so here B5 yes B5 Bishop D3
maybe take take and um like try to move
A4 was interesting yes I fought with the
dn97 97 96.
I was thinking to play Rook C2 if a
knight to the seventh and E4 it seems
like you also have maybe the idea of
writing no but but she will block it she
will block it first I think it's not a
tool 97.
that's the night before
a Rooks
yes yes and now get Knights yeah so
that's why we're thinking maybe
and E4 so that was like very concerned
about move A4 here
because yeah
she was starting to look at this side of
the board and rather uh yeah yeah it was
like positionally she was just a
misplacing her pieces was that a little
optimistic for her to no I think she
just simply didn't know what to do
probably so definitely she doesn't hit
Rook on age right yeah so this is 97 A4
so this was important of course very
important to play for and I'm like just
much much better after this moves
because now you have full control of the
C5 Square managed to get Knight to B3
yeah and after that it felt like quite a
clean game you were building up and
building up your initiative it's
interesting the variant like if you go
like in the variant was very nice some
tactics I was likely to play Queen E1 I
I saw it um at this point yeah to this
point I was calculating also a night a
night of four instead of Knight DeForest
was also interesting for her but I think
it was like the same idea take take and
Blake win F3
here
so that's why you're talking of one and
then and then the same idea since I have
my phone on A5 I have this A6 and you're
running yeah yeah and in the game was
also I I like her to grab my Rook but
okay it's like it was the same once
again yeah once again yes
and just in case calculated Knight B3
not just one Temple she's not enough
V6 but unfortunately for her it did not
uh work out Anna um for the first time
or at least in many years this
tournament has four 13 routes that's a
very very long tournament I never played
13 Rounds in US championship
special uh maybe in preparation my bills
felt good for me because I came here I
was in Germany so I still have uh yeah
and maybe I will play better in the rest
of the game so
I don't know what is better I will tell
you after the tronum excellent Anna
congratulations for the victory we'll
see you in the rest of your games thank
you indeed our congratulations
congratulations as well on